did you know that val kilmer's 2017
throat cancer diagnosis largely robbed
the actor of his ability to speak so
given his physical limitations did
kilmer enjoy reprising his role as
iceman and top gun maverick here's how
kilmer really feels about his role in
top gun maverick after its release was
delayed two years due to the
uncertainties of the kobe 19 pandemic
fans are finally feeling the need for
speed again with the release of top gun
maverick the long-awaited sequel
naturally finds tom cruise reprising his
role as ace fighter pilot pete maverick
mitchell but he's not the only star from
the 1986 original top gun to return for
the sequel venerable actor val kilmer
despite a harrowing battle with throat
cancer in recent years is back in
reprising his iconic role of tom iceman
kazansky and top gun maverick i don't
like you because you're dangerous that's
right
nice
man
i am dangerous maverick and iceman of
course were rivals for much of top gun
but ultimately reconciled their
differences in the midst of a deadly dog
fight with the enemy in the final act of
the film new in theaters top gun
maverick reveals that maverick and
iceman's friendship endured in the
decades since the events of top gun
which is why ice now an admiral calls on
his old buddy and colleague to return to
the top gun program to prepare its top
10 fighter pilots for a crucial mission
but while a reunion of cruz and kilmer
and top gun maverick seemed like a
no-brainer and an easy task for cruz and
his collaborators getting kilmer to
reprise iceman was tricky due to the
actors real-life health battles in
recent years in 2017 val kilmer revealed
that he was diagnosed with throat cancer
which largely robbed him of his ability
to speak
the actor whose impressive list of
credits includes such movie classics as
tombstone and heat went very public with
the lasting effects of his cancer fight
in the 2021 amazon prime documentary
bowel during the documentary kilmer
demonstrates how he can only speak by
plugging a hole in a tube in his
esophagus which gives off a low and
gravely tone despite kilmer's health
issues the uk's express online reported
that cruz did not want to make top gun
maverick without comer's participation
cruz revealed i really rallied hard for
him to be in the movie because he's such
a tremendous actor and i wanted to have
him play that character according to the
publication kilmer's son jack who sounds
remarkably like his father as he
narrates val lent his voice to top gun
maverick and the production used new
technology to combine their performances
the startling result is shown in an
emotional reunion scene between maverick
and iceman cruz told express you see
that scene and it's very special it's
just very special he's beautiful in
addition to his assistance with her
father's work on the documentary val
jack kilmer along with his sister
mercedes kilmer were both on set in san
diego when val kilmer filmed his reunion
scene with cruz in the scene between
kilmer and cruz iceman suffering from an
illness implied to be cancer first
communicates with maverick by typing
words that appear on a computer screen
ice eventually speaks to his dear friend
but his voice is clearly affected by the
illness
kilmer's appearance in top gun maverick
is a validation of sorts of what he
described in his documentary yes there
was a rivalry between maverick and
iceman in the film but that's where the
rivalry stayed off screen the
relationship between kilmer and cruz was
much friendlier kilmer noted in val it
was fun to play up the conflict between
our characters but in reality i've
always thought of tom as a friend and
we've always supported each other in a
video released by the tech company
synantic in august 2021 the company
revealed that they culled together old
recordings of kilmer to create a
computer-generated version of his voice
to remarkable effect a phrase we often
hear is
having a creative voice
kilmer was so impressed by what synantic
produced that he issued a statement
saying
synantic masterfully restored my voice
in a way i've never imagined possible
whether kilmer will appear in future
projects with the aid of voice
technology is yet to be seen in the
meantime yahoo entertainment reported
that the actor will very much have a
presence in the upcoming willow series
on disney plus which is based on the
original 1988 film starring kilmer and
warwick davis series executive producer
jonathan casden told yahoo val's a huge
part of this and the first conversation
i had when warwick and i got the green
light to do this was with mal we wanted
his character to be a part of the story
we wanted him to be in the show and
we're pretty excited about it mad
martign lives on
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one